I similarly had a vivid dream this
weekend, and [music] Charlie came to me
and he told me that he was betrayed. Is
this idea of these dreams and someone
from the dead specifically [music]
speaking to you, is that biblical? The
origins of the idea of this concept of
the eternal soul, it actually comes from
pagan beliefs and pagan systems, right?
You have the Protestants coming in, but
they still kept a lot of the concepts
that [music] originally pagan. If you
ask people then like, well, what does
the Bible say happens then when you die?
Well, the Bible actually talks about
that you are essentially
Some people might never have heard of
this before, and they may be like, "What
are you talking about? The Bible's clear
that
>> I want you guys to know something. I
want to share this with you. You can
take it or you can leave it, but [music]
Charlie was betrayed.
I know this. Uh
I I've known this really since the first
second, but I rarely have vivid dreams.
And I did [music] in fact have a very
vivid one over the weekend. In fact,
last time that I I had a super vivid
dream, I was pregnant. It tends to
happen a lot uh to women when they're
pregnant, but [music] in that dream from
2023, my former producer of the show and
I
uh were standing in the control room,
and she told me that she was 26 weeks
pregnant. This is in the dream.
>> [music]
>> And she told me exactly what month the
baby was coming. I asked her in the
dream, "Is it a boy? Is it a girl?" And
she said, "It's a boy."
I woke up, and I immediately texted my
producer in real life, and I said, "Hey,
you're pregnant. Just [music] so you
know, it's a boy."
And then she found out that she was
pregnant 1 week later. She had no idea
when I texted her. And something that we
reflected on a couple of months later
because she was just totally shocked
looking back on it. And this is our our
our text chain [music]
uh from you can see 2023. She said, "You
texted me June [music] 16th,
and I think I got pregnant June 26th.
This is crazy,
>> [music]
>> and it's going to be a boy. It's nuts."
I said, "I'm telling you your baby
visited me. It was an insanely vivid
dream. He was on his way."
>> [music]
>> And she said, "That is so bizarre. My
mom also texted me that week saying that
she had a dream I was pregnant."
>> [music]
>> I said, "I haven't had a dream that
vivid since. It's been my only vivid
dream this entire pregnancy.
>> [music]
>> I believe people can communicate in
dreams on their way in and on their way
out of this world." I similarly, like I
just said, had a vivid dream this
weekend, and Charlie [music]
came to me and he told me that he was
betrayed. And so for me, you don't have
to believe that, but [music] I do
believe that.
And uh
it was the immediate sense I got
actually.
And [music]
I don't know who exactly it is that
betrayed him, but I also felt in the
dream that it is soon going to be
revealed, that it's actually inevitable,
that it is going to be revealed, that
there is nothing and no one that is
going to stop the truth from coming out,
and it is going to have international
consequences.
Take that [music] to the bank. Quote me
on that. First reaction. Wow. You know,
like I mean, she's making a pretty bold
statement here.
I It's interesting to see how the whole
Charlie Kirk thing has been received and
what people are doing with that, but I I
think that theologically I have some
problems with that. What about you?
I think that's very challenging. I mean,
I understand people dream things and
they they
have them as very sincere held beliefs,
but at the same time
I mean, if you were to take every dream
>> Mhm. that you ever had Yeah. and was
like, "You know what? This happened in
my dream, so I believe it."
I get it. She's not making a case for
every dream. She's saying, "Well, this
doesn't happen to me very often, but
I don't know. Still, I I
you know, I I think what bothered me was
the part where she said
uh she believes people can communicate
on their way in and on their way out. I
There's just a lot of questions there. I
believe people can communicate in dreams
on their way in and on their way out of
this world. Yeah, I mean, they would
they would have a to If it's a baby
coming in, right? The baby would have to
know English and be Yes, that's actually
true.
>> Well, I mean, yeah. [laughter] Yeah. So
then it goes back to like it doesn't
know anything when it's a baby.
And that's weird.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So So yeah, that's weird.
It's It's interesting she's talking
about she's having a dream, right? And
she's talking about, yeah, when you're
pregnant, you just have very vivid
dreams. Like to me, it's just a normal
And And don't get me wrong. In the
Bible, God did give people dreams,
right? And it says in the last days,
young men shall dream dreams and they
shall see visions, etc.
But the thing is, like yeah, this is a
natural phenomenon, and the fact is that
if you're thinking in your brain, "Well,
Charlie's been betrayed," your brain is
processing your thoughts, and even it
even processes trauma in your REM sleep
and your deep sleep. So it's very likely
that that exact picture you already had
in your head then comes up in your
dream. Like that's not unusual. So
There's some very questionable things
that I think that um as we get further
away from this this terrible thing that
happened to Charlie Kirk
that it just doesn't make sense. And I
think that you know, you could probably
go around in circles of like who did
this, why did they do this, and and all
these things, right? But But you see the
reaction of what is actually happening,
and to me, it's like I would not put it
past
the devil to use this situation to usher
people into a particular form of
worship. Yeah. I think I I agree. I
think it's a highly suspicious thing
that happened. It's weird. It's odd.
It's like, what's going on? I mean, I
don't think it should be a distraction
is what I mean. We should look at what's
the result of this. I agree. And there's
some things about the um you know, the
people communicating with you that it's
they're dead.
That's the thing that I think is is
problematic in my mind. Yeah. The Bible
says um
in Amos, I think it's 37, "Surely the
Lord God does nothing unless he reveals
his secrets to his servants the
prophets."
And as much as God would probably want
everybody to be a prophet, like Moses
said, "I wish that all the Lord's people
were were prophets." That's not the
case.
And there's specific criteria in the
Bible for somebody to
be able to have that gift. And then, you
know, just because there is a you know,
prophetic utterance doesn't doesn't
necess- It doesn't mean that it's not
subject to scripture. Like it already
has to agree with something that God
already said. It's not like he's going
to just say like, "Okay, well, here's
all this stuff written in the Bible, but
I'm going to give you a prophecy, and it
has nothing to do with that, and you
can't check it with the Bible, you know.
It's just kind of out there."
So then it brings to mind like, well,
you know, what do you what do you do
with that? Is this a religious thing? Is
that what you're implying?
You know, it's given to you as a
religious thing because you're a
believing kind of person.
Or
like you said, is it just something you
were thinking about? And so you're
predisposed to
Yeah, and I think also the Bible is
clear there's a certain list, a certain
order of how you can know whether
someone is a true prophet or not, right?
I'm not saying that Candace Owens is a
prophet by any means, and I'm not saying
that she's implying that. I think she's
probably very genuine in in her beliefs.
And also, knowing that she's a Catholic
convert, this is very prominent within
Catholicism to, you know, speak to the
dead people, to speak to dead um saints,
and and that the saints can communicate
can communicate with you and are
currently in heaven, or or some people
are burning in hell, and they can talk
to you, you know. So So I don't want to
claim that she's not being genuine in
this, but I Yeah, I do think we should
look at, you know,
is this idea of these these dreams and
someone from the dead specifically
speaking to you, is that biblical? Well,
I think that that God is is giving us a
picture of what happens when you die in
the Bible, so that that the lying
spirits cannot
utilize that and and manipulate you.
Because yeah, I mean, if you're if
you're, you know, seeing visions of
people and, you know, entities are
showing up and talking with you um if
you really were a spirit that like
seconds you die and you're floating
around, then then yeah, why wouldn't you
listen to the information that they're
telling you?
>> Mhm. And if you were the devil, you know
that you would make sure that some of
that information exactly was true. It
Yeah, it's always mixed with truth,
right? Truth and error blended together.
It's just not truth.
>> That's right. That's right.
>> You can't just say a complete absolute
lie. You know, nobody [clears throat]
would ever believe it, but if it's mixed
with truth Right. So I would I I want to
kind of start this off with dropping a
bit of a ball here, or bomb I should
say. Some people might never have heard
of this before, and they may be like,
"What are you talking about? The Bible's
clear that the the dead can come and
communicate with us and all that." But
just to give a bit of a background, and
I've shared this on the show before, but
for those who haven't heard it, the the
origins of the idea of this this concept
of the the eternal soul, it actually
comes from pagan beliefs and pagan
systems, [clears throat] right? And then
it came from the Greeks, and it came to
from to the Romans, and and yeah, there
was this this concept of like there's
this entity that's inside of you, and
it's going to come out of you, and it's
going to float around when it's dead and
haunt you, and all this kind of things.
Well, eventually, as history shows us,
you know, we had Jesus came, and we had
the Jews, and then out of that came the
Christian church. And God has always had
a pure Christian church throughout
history that kept with you know, God's
truth and his commandments and his word,
etc.
But as Roman Emperor Constantine, again,
Roman, right? As he became a convert,
and I should go like this,
he started blending paganism, his Roman
beliefs, and and even the concept of the
soul, and all that kind of stuff came in
with He started blending that with
Christianity. And then, you know, a long
time later, history shows us out of that
system ideas came the Roman Catholic
Church. Eventually, the Roman Catholic
Church became the world power, even
ruling over kings and authorities and
governments. And so that was the belief.
And then came out the Protestant
Reformation, and they started fighting
back against a lot of these Roman
Catholic beliefs, but of course, as you
guys know, eventually you had the um
you know, the Protestants coming in, but
they still kept a lot of the concepts
that were originally pagan, you know,
and
you know, like I said, the Bible doesn't
actually confirm this at all that we're
supposedly have
souls, all right, like coming out of us.
Or that the soul is can be um existing
separate outside of the body. Mhm. Um I
think like the verse that comes to mind
in Ezekiel 18:20, it says, "The soul
that sinneth, it shall die." And if that
soul is dead, I mean,
you know, Keith brought up a good point
when we were talking about this before
we we started the show. Um you know,
Lazarus. Mhm. Right? What what what was
said about Lazarus?
From his sister.
She was confident that he would be
raised up in the last day at the
resurrection. Right. Which would mean
that he was dead dead. Like he's not
floating around or she didn't say,
"Well, he's going to come back to heaven
and inhabit his body and then be raised
up."
>> Yeah. And he had nothing to say when he
was resurrected about what he
experienced and there's nothing
recorded.
>> Yeah, we've talked about this many
times. If you came If you were in
heaven, your your test is over. You've
made it. And then you get called back
down to your body, you'd be upset.
>> You'd be like, "Oh, sucks." Like, "What?
I got to die again?" What's going on,
Jesus? be upset. But but that doesn't
just happen with Lazarus, also with
talking about the the the the the second
coming of Jesus. So, now you've been on
in heaven for like who knows how long
and then you're going to put back into
your mortal body to then be transformed
into your heavenly body to go back.
Yeah. It doesn't make sense. Revelation
16:3 says, "Every living soul died in
the sea."
>> Mhm. I mean, there's some verses here
that really talk about the soul and um
you know, only God is immortal. And you
have to remember that. Like what is
offered to us as salvation and
immortality, that's us putting on
immortality when Jesus comes back.
Again, God is the only one that has that
at this point and he's giving that to
you. So, you know, if you die and all of
a sudden your soul just like bounces up
and goes somewhere, it's like you didn't
really die then. And that's not what the
Bible teaches. There's a there's a
really interesting story in 1 Samuel.
Um Is this about the the witch of Endor
or no?
>> It is. 1 Samuel 28. It tells us Samuel
died, Israel was lamenting for him, he
was buried, you know. And it tells us
that King Saul, he had put away the
mediums, the spiritists, all those kind
of people out of the land. Now, do you
know why he did that? I think he was
told to, right? Yeah, but but also if
you look at chapters like uh Deuteronomy
18,
very clear. Like Oh, yeah, the don't go
to wizards and You you don't communicate
with these people.
>> Yeah. Under any circumstances
whatsoever.
>> Or they got the death punishment.
>> Like like those people were always under
a death penalty if they [clears throat]
were found to be in the land of Israel.
So, like
exact opposite. Like God has very strong
language. Language, yeah. He has very
strong feelings, very strong opinions
about people who are in those classes,
right? So, they bury Samuel and then
um Saul has this problem with the
Philistines and he's afraid. Doesn't
know what to do. Says his heart trembled
greatly.
And
it says that Saul goes and inquires of
the Lord.
>> Mhm. That That should always be step
one. We should always inquire of the
Lord. Anything anytime we have a
problem, go inquire of the Lord, right?
But it says the Lord did not answer him.
Mhm. Mhm. You ever had that happen? Yes.
Yeah. You inquire of the Lord, you don't
get an answer, right?
>> Mhm.
You wait at that point. You have That's
the proper answer. Why do you think God
didn't answer him? Maybe he he wanted to
reveal to Saul what was in his heart and
and if he was going to be genuine.
Isn't this where the Holy Spirit left
him before just before? This is almost
at the end of his life. Yeah, the Holy
Spirit left him in Yeah, in the in the
beginning. had left him before.
>> It was the beginning. Yeah. I thought it
was towards the end as well. Like just
before the story. In the beginning of
his career when he sacrificed the
animals he was supposed to wait for.
That was the beginning. And and that
said the spirit of the God left him at
that point.
>> Yeah, so basically he sinned against the
Holy Spirit. Like he was done. But in
this case, he was already done and so
obviously He's at the end of his life.
>> Yeah.
And so, it's no wonder that the the Lord
doesn't answer him because he's already
demonstrated if God tells him something,
he's not listening anyway, right? Right?
So, it says the Lord did not answer him
either by dreams. So, the Lord can give
dreams.
>> Yep.
Okay. Or by Urim or by the prophets.
Yeah, the Urim and the Thummim were the
Mhm. the
>> the two stones that sat on the high
priest.
>> Yeah. Yeah. On his shoulders. So, God
can God can communicate by dreams.
>> Mhm.
But what is he going to communicate by
dreams? What he's going to do, his will,
things having to do with his work.
>> Right.
>> just communicate anything and everything
by dreams. It's not because the problem
is when we get to that point when we
think God just communicates everything
by dreams, then we start to bypass the
Bible.
>> Yep. Mhm. Right, things that are already
written. And it's like when you
communicate a biblical truth to somebody
and they say, "I'll pray about it."
Prayer is not a substitute for doing
what God has already said. Just like
dreams are always to
basically to confirm what's already
written or to show the future that God
is in control, right? So, like with
Joseph, with Daniel, right?
Nebuchadnezzar had dreams, the Pharaoh
had dreams and they came to interpret
them, but they had to have that
person who was in touch with God to help
her interpret and interface and and show
them what was going on.
It goes on and uh and then he said,
"Find me a woman who's a medium that I
might go and inquire of her."
So, wait. So, he go he's like
God's not listening. He's not answering
my prayer, which God had told him
through Samuel earlier like your time is
up, basically.
He does it anyway. He goes to God. God's
like not answering because I already
told you. And he's like, "Well, I'm just
going to go against the word of God
again and inquire of a medium."
Yeah.
And and the guy, you know, when the the
woman said to him, "Look, you know what
Saul has done.
He's cut off the mediums, he's cut off
the spiritists of the land. Uh you're
putting a snare for my life to cause me
to die." She knew the penalty. It was
death. I get caught, it's on it's on my
head. And so, he has to swear to her
like, "No, we're not going to do that to
you. We're not going to kill you." So,
again, he's disobeying
God because he that should have been the
penalty for
>> should have been a warning to him as
well. Like remember what the scriptures
say. You're not supposed to do this.
Yeah.
And then the woman said, "Who shall I
bring up for you?"
And he's like, "Bring up Samuel for me."
And he comes out of the ground. Yeah, as
an old man. Yeah, yeah. Like you go to
heaven, you're supposed to be in your
youth, right? Yeah, have a divine body.
Yeah. But he bypasses God.
Mhm.
So, if God it Think about it this way.
If God is like, "No spiritists, no
medium. Don't go to these people. In
fact, if you encounter them,
kill them."
How much good do you think would ever
come from one of those people?
>> Mhm. I mean, it's also a lesson in in
just how debased our own ideas can be if
we think that, you know, we can operate
outside of God. Could that Could that
person ever be communicating truth?
Yeah, right. No. No.
>> the Bible clearly says that necromancy
is a sin. Like you're not supposed to
Necromancy meaning speaking to the dead.
>> Yeah, they could not communicate truth
at all. So, that means they're playing
for team Satan. Mhm. Right?
>> Yeah, it's obvious. Playing for team
Satan. Yeah. So, then
she she does what he asks and he
perceives, it says I think that's the
word. Some translations say
perceives Yeah. spirit of Samuel. Yeah.
Just like many people perceive their
dead grandmother or whatever it is. And
Saul perceived it was Samuel. That's
what it That's what it said. She
describes this old guy. I mean, there
could have been lots of old guys, right?
>> [laughter]
>> But she gives a description that makes
him think, "Oh, yeah, that's that's the
guy I'm looking for." Mhm. And of
course,
it speaks to him,
this thing,
speaks to him,
"Why have you disturbed me by bringing
me up?"
He knew this was playing with fire.
He knew this was wrong.
And he's distressed and he asks what to
do
from a devil or demon at this case.
Yeah, and it the thing answers him like,
"Why do you ask me seeing the Lord has
departed from you and has become your
enemy?"
So, it's like he's like telling him the
truth. Like, "Dude, you're s- What's
crazy is is like, you know, you got to
you got to think like Satan also is
trying to buy everybody's um
like like faith in him. Yeah. So, he's
telling him something that he's like,
"Haha, now you stepped on my ground and
I can cause this thing to happen because
you aren't protected by God anymore."
And so, he can of course give him the
yeah, you're going to lose your life and
and make that happen. And then what does
that do to everybody that believes in
this story?
Yeah. That there's valid, you know,
information that you can learn from
these people. Listen to what
Ecclesiastes
9:5, 6, and 10 say.
"The living know that they will die, but
the dead know not anything. They have no
more reward and the memory of them is
forgotten. Also, their love, their
hatred, and their envy have now
perished. Never will they have a share
in anything done under the sun, anything
done under the sun."
I mean, listen to that. That's
Yeah, put those two stories together.
Yeah. Did Samuel love Saul? He did. He
He basically mourned over Saul like a
father mourns over his child.
Did And And so [clears throat] if if
Samuel doesn't have If his memory is
forgotten
if he has nothing more to say
>> no nothing. And yeah, and look at what
verse 10 says, "There is no work or
device or knowledge or wisdom in the
grave where you are going. The dead do
not praise the Lord." Mhm. Yeah. So, are
you in heaven praising the Lord? Not
according to that scripture. Are you
doing anything under the sun? Nope. If
the sun's out there, you are not under
that sun doing anything. That's pretty
dead clear. So, so let's talk about then
what is a soul? Cuz we got to briefly
talked about the origins of it and the
concept. Genesis 2:7 says, "And the Lord
God formed man of the dust of the ground
and breathed into his nostrils the
breath of life and man became a living
soul." So, if you minus any of those
equations Yeah. So, breath of God, the
breath of life that we have in us,
right? And And also in the Bible clearly
says that the the animals and the fish
in the sea they all have the breath of
from of life from God. You take that and
you take away the fact that we have a
body cuz the body when we die
decomposes. This says you have nothing,
right? This So, you do breath minus soul
equates nothing. You're You're dead.
You're So, basically a soul is just a
living being. In fact, King James
Version says in this verse
a soul, they became a soul, but the New
King James translated at a as a living
being and many modern translations
translates it as
a living being. Is which exactly what it
is. There's a lot of verses that that
speak um to this sort of like what's
happening. Revelation 22:12 says,
"Behold, I'm coming quickly and my
reward is with me to give to everyone
according to his work."
You know, it's like
the reward is not given the second you
die. Mhm.
>> Yeah. The reward is given at the end of
the of the time and when people are
resurrected. Yeah, that's when the bi- I
mean bi- it's in 1 Thessalonians and uh
1 Corinthians Well, 1 Thessalonians 4, 1
Corinthians 15 tell you that
immortality is essentially bestowed when
Jesus comes back. Like you don't have it
before then. Only God has it.
Yeah, and then also uh I'm just looking
this up right now these various verses.
The idea of So, if you ask people then
like Well, what does the Bible say
happens then when you die? Well, the
Bible actually talks about specifically
in the story of Lazarus that you are
essentially asleep. Not meaning like
like you're sleeping like physically how
we tonight we go to bed and we sleep, it
means that you close your eyes and as
soon as you open your eyes if you were
in the Lord then you will see the
resurrection of Jesus, right? The second
coming. Mhm.
>> So, John 11:11-14 says, "Our friend
Lazarus sleeps, but I go to that I may
wake him up." Then his disciples said,
"Lord, if he sleeps, he will get well."
However, Jesus Jesus spoke of his death,
but they thought that he was speaking
about taking rest and sleep. And Jesus
said to them plainly, "Lazarus is dead."
>> So, and there's other instances as well.
Daniel 12:2 and many of those who sleep
in the dust of the earth shall awake,
some to everlasting life, some to shame
and everlasting contempt.
>> John 5:28 and 29, "All those that are in
the graves will hear his voice and come
forth." And he's calling the the
righteous that died in Christ or that
will be brought to heaven to be
resurrected at that point. So, you know,
it's like there's David is both Here's
Acts 2:29 to and 34. David is both dead
and buried and his tomb is with us to to
this day for David did not ascend into
the heavens.
>> Yeah.
And you And you find the reverse is uh
true as well. You take somebody like
Ananias and Sapphira, they lied to the
Holy Spirit.
Drop dead just like that. So, if they
don't have their reward yet, they're
also in the grave of waiting reward.
It's not going to be a good reward.
But they're waiting that reward and it's
fair. It's a fair system, I think. God
is fair.
Right? It's a fair system. So, if
everybody gets their reward at the same
time, that means nobody is suffering
longer than somebody else.
And it means that nobody is
with the exception of a few people like
Moses enjoying their reward longer than
somebody else, right?
>> and Elijah [clears throat] because
they're shown
with Jesus.
>> that, but yeah.
I think the reality is if you actually
lived a terrible life, which there's
people that have I I mean just the worst
imaginable like situations in life,
abused, you know, drug addicts,
whatever, they believe in God and
they're just like, you know, have this
absolute terrible life.
And if you really honestly believe that
the second I die I'm going I'm going
right to heaven, why would you not just
end your life? Why would you even suffer
for any any period in
You know [clears throat] that you're
going to just go straight up. So, I
think this kind of really bends what's
happening and I think you have to take
the Bible as a whole and and go there's
way more verses that support the idea
that when you die, you are ceasing to
exist until Jesus comes again and he
will hand you whether your reward is for
good or for evil. I think the thing with
Charlie is it becomes very emotional.
Yeah. It becomes very politically
charged, you know, people want to
believe things happened or didn't happen
a certain way. They want to believe that
for for personal reasons, emotional
reasons, political reasons, all of that.
At the end of the day, I just, you know,
hope Charlie's in heaven.
Hope Candace is in heaven. Like when the
second coming happens?
>> know that. Yeah, when the second coming
happens. I hope they make it. I don't
know that. I mean I don't know what was
going on in I don't know what goes on is
on in either one of their minds or what
their relationship truly is with God. I
mean, you know.
>> The point is is if you
leave yourself wide open for
communication with the spirits. Yeah. I
think that you are setting yourself up
for receiving the wrong information or
they can easily get in and now bend you
and it and and if it is an emotionally
charged thing, if a loved one or a
family member or somebody you really
truly care about you're going to listen
to that person. If somebody shows up
like as your father or your mother and
you really care about that person and
they're like, "Look, I've been in
heaven. This is what it's like and you
should do this." That's going to be a
difficult emotional experience for
people and that's why I think that we
it's imperative that we need to
understand the state of the dead. And
And I know we're going to have a lot of
comments of people that disagree with us
and that's okay because I you know,
people have the freedom to do so and and
I would rather have people to start up a
conversation with us than just like
throw it throwing the baby out the
bathwater, you know, like let's let's
all study this together. Um but
you know, if people want to study into
this deeper because I know there's going
to be people say like, "What about this
in the story in the Bible? What about
that one and that one?" Yeah. The really
best resource that I have found
personally that I've used many times is
the website called truthaboutdeath.com
and ghosttruth.com. There's also
helltruth.com. So, they have a Q&A
section on truthaboutdeath that
literally asks all kinds of questions
like, "What is the spirit that returns
to God at death?" There's verses about
that, right? Talking about Samuel and
Saul at the in the witch of Endor. Paul,
"Absent with the from the body is
present with the Lord." I've heard that
one a lot. Um "Are spirits of just men
made perfect after death?" Didn't Jesus
preach to the spirits in prison? Lazarus
and the rich man. Uh the gospel being
preached to the dead. Paul preferred to
be depart to be with the Lord. Right?
So, there's there's so many thief on the
cross with Jesus. Some people infer that
it means that he went to paradise to
heaven today. But, you know, if when you
really study your Bible and you really
don't take like, "Oh, this is just what
the mainstream Christianity believes so
therefore I will believe it." Like look
at your Bible yourselves. Really read
the scriptures. Compare scripture to
scripture in the text. And when you use
these Q&A's where they do that, it's
like, "Wow, this is actually perfectly
clear." You bring up a good point
because Jesus says, "If you seek me, you
will find me." Right? And if you really
come to God with a a open heart, "Show
me the truth here, God. Let the Holy
Spirit speak to my mind. Tell me what
the truth is this is and I'm going to
study this out and whatever way it is
then Lord, I give you permission to show
show me." If you approach God like that,
he will tell you. But have an open heart
with God like that. But if you come to
God and you just say, "Show me the
truth. If there's error here, show me
the error. If there's truth here, show
me the truth." And I think that every
single time you do that with God with
any truth, God will share it with you.
Yeah. We need to be careful about
predisposing ourselves to
personalized views of truth based on
what we think is some kind of
revelation.
You know, the Bible says that it's not
privately interpreted.
>> Yep. And I believe the same is is true
for the other. Do people have
experiences with God? Yes. Does God
speak to people in personal ways? Yes.
But we have to be very careful with this
kind of, you know,
thing that's God communicated this very
specific thing
to me. Has to line up with scripture.
>> And I And you know, let's pray for
Candace Owens that she
Like we talked about, we don't know her
heart. We don't know where she's at. We
don't know where Charlie Kirk was at.
God knows and God will show everybody
who wants to know the truth the truth
including Candace Owens.
>> [music]
[music]